i have to say uh first of all um
this has been a long hard pandemic for
all of us
very difficult yeah but uh i have to say
and many people complain that they have
um well they've they've not been
exercising they've been eating
incorrectly
you on the other hand look fantastic you
appear to be in incredible shape thank
you colin yes just like the marmalade
i've been pumping up the jams since
march 11
i immediately ordered one glove and five
dumbbells when i found out a pandemic
was coming wait so your first order
was not to try and get toilet paper or
lots of uh masks you ordered one mask
and
how many dumbbells one glove because the
toilet paper was sold
oh oh you got a glove improvised
you used a glove instead of toilet paper
i had no teepees what did you use
i used two gloves handful spread one for
clean
uh old friend if i can call you that
okay what is it in german old friend
yeah izafran
hi the flooring yeah um listen uh so
you've been working out constantly
during this pandemic oh very deeply yes
you know for the film suicide squad i
was told listen flula you will be
playing a hero slash villain slash who
knows so i needed to pump up all of my
bottoms all of my tarpies all of my
boobies
so i just did it i went hard so uh so
which
are the parts of your body that you
really focused on your chests
uh i saw you walk in i have to say when
you walked into this theater
and listen i am uh you know a straight
man okay but i was like
what the hell is happening here uh chess
the torso the abs your buttocks you
seems like you put a lot of work into
your buttocks well i would show you more
but this is what television not
tick tock i mean i don't know what
you're talking i am as well confused
i did one was worrying about my buttocks
so i didn't receive a photo of what is
the character looking like my character
javelin so i thought
why not make big buttocks just like that
song from destination child booty dishes
yes um it's destiny's child it's not
destination
it's not destination colon child it's
destiny's child you're certain
destination
child that was never the name of that
group i am i'm not certain they started
in europe they were definitely we're
destination child people
okay listen um again i'm confused by
most of what you say flula
but i'm glad that you're in terrific i
bet you could clench your buttocks right
now and fire yourself up to the ceiling
not don i want to see it i just bet you
could yeah in syria what happened